Warum habe ich hier oben einen 403 Fehler?
Was ist das? Warum habe ich hier oben einen 403 Fehler?
Hä? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Man muss nicht alles verstehen.
Ach ich weiß warum.
Oder auch nicht Poggers, das ist irgendein Tippy Stream Widget was kaputt ist.
Na toll.
Warum ist das Tippy Stream Widget kaputt?
Mal gucken, gibt es die vielleicht nicht mehr?
Vielleicht gibt es die nicht mehr.
Oder ist die Seite, die Seite ist gerade down.
Die Seite ist, ne.
Die Seite ist nicht down.
Alert Box.
You cannot access this Widget. Was ist das für ein Fail Alter?
What the fuck?
Refresh.
You cannot access this Widget.
Auch geil.
Tippy Stream gerade kaputt würde ich sagen.
Ich habe es gerade ausprobiert, also anscheinend ist die Alert Box für Donations im Arsch.
Gut, kann ich beleben? Ich kriege eh kaum Donations.
Und jetzt kann man ja auch mittlerweile Summen oder Bits spenden oder so.
Also Donations sind kaputt Leute. Donations sind 403.
403 heißt ich darf nicht.
403 ist der HTTP-Fehlercode für keinen Zugriff erlaubt.
403 ja.
Hier oben müsste das ungefähr sein.
Was ist jetzt verschoben? Wow.
Ach guck mal da.
Mein Tool ist verbackt, ich kann die Dinger gar nicht aus dem Bild schieben.
Was ist da los?
Hier, zack.
Hab ich noch nie probiert.
Zack.
Snapped, das Snapped zurück.
Vielleicht ist es aber auch Monka Windows, kann auch sein.
Max was geht?
Es geht gerade, dass ich ziemlich voll gefressen bin.
Und ich mir gedacht habe, das ist die optimale Voraussetzung jetzt zu streben.
Ja warum ich das nicht verschieben darf, weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube da muss ich mein Meme-Tool nochmal überarbeiten.
Hm, komisch.
Ja gut, da kann man nichts machen.
Was machst du heute schönes? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Soll ich euch mal den aktuellen Fortschritt zeigen?
Vom Versand-Tracksor, der ist jetzt richtig gut mittlerweile.
Du lebst ja noch, warum soll ich nicht leben?
Ich mein komm Leute, der letzte Stream ist wie lange her?
5 Tage?
Also dass ich in 5 Tagen noch nicht gestorben bin.
Ich denke das war anzunehmen.
Moin, Mob Ina TV.
Ach, bei der Gelegenheit. Warum sind meine Desktop-Icons so riesig?
Dass ich sie besser sehe.
Was gibt es eigentlich für Gamescom Pressekonferenzen dieses Jahr?
Vielleicht soll ich das mal auf Deutsch suchen.
Hallo?
Kann man Google-Auto-Vervollstellung funktionieren?
Alle Pressekonferenzen in der Übersicht.
Wo steht es denn?
Ich muss jetzt mal dieses 403 ausblenden, ich glaube das fixt sich von selbst nicht.
Donation-Rip, gehen keine Donations heute.
Sollte mir jemand was donaten, werde ich es nicht merken.
Also anstatt zu donaten, als ihr das vor habt, macht lieber einen kostenlosen Twitch-Prime-Sub.
Oder Bits.
Oder auch gar nichts.
Was ja auch vollkommen legitim ist.
Warum keine Discord-Benachrichtigungen? Gute Frage.
Warum hat der Bot keine Discord-Benachrichtigungen verschickt?
Gucken wir doch mal.
Wo ist der Bot sowas da?
Tatsächlich.
Bot.
Bots raus.
Der Bot hat keinen Bock Ankündigungen zu machen.
Der hat Montag auch nicht gecheckt, dass ich online war.
War ich Montag überhaupt online?
Igitt, was ist das?
Wonka, Win.
Geh weg.
Der Noss.
Der Bot hat das nicht gecheckt.
Ja, ich hätte nicht so viel futtern sollen heute Abend.
Der hat da nichts gegessen.
Bis jetzt um halb sechs.
Und als ich mir gedacht habe, holst du da was zu essen?
Jetzt habe ich so viel gefuttert, jetzt bin ich übelst im Arsch.
Also hier übelst Residenz-Sleeper.
Gab es denn Schweinelände mit Semmelknödel?
Pfifferling, Stelz und auf den Spinat dabei hätte ich verzichten können.
Das ist richtig Kokona.
So sehe ich echt einmal aus.
Klingt edel.
Das hat auch 16 Euro gekostet.
10 Euro.
Eigentlich viel zu teuer.
Aber was macht man nicht, wenn man Hunger hat.
Für 17 Euro war die Portion gar nicht so groß, wie sie hätte sein sollen.
Ich meine, ich bin trotzdem satt.
Aber ich hätte davor noch mehr essen können.
Keine Frage, wenn das Zeug gut schmeckt, kann man immer mehr futtern.
Was ist eigentlich die neue G502 Lightspeed?
Habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es eine neue G502 überhaupt gibt.
Give me one reason not to upgrade.
Weil Logitech nicht genug bezahlt hat.
Was hat die jetzt besseres als die andere?
Die sieht ziemlich genau aus, wie so eine G502 aussieht.
Ach, die ist wireless.
Warum sind eigentlich alle Maushersteller mittlerweile so scharf drauf, Mäuse wireless zu machen?
Ich meine, das ist auch nur eine Maus.
Das Lightspeed kostet extra.
Ich meine, man kann mittlerweile ohne Probleme Wireless-Mäuse bauen, die jetzt auch keine großartigen Latenzprobleme haben oder so.
Aber muss es wireless sein?
Ich habe überhaupt gar keine Bestrebungen oder überhaupt kein Verlangen nach einer Wireless-Maus.
Powerplay Wireless Charging.
Okay, wenn du das passende findest, ist das ganze Mauspad Charged das?
Oder ist das der Charger, wo man die Maus dann irgendwie drauf stellen muss?
Ah nee, das ist das ganze Mauspad.
Das muss nicht sein.
Ich meine, nochmal 130 Euro.
Ich meine, warum sollte ich 280 Euro ausgeben für eine Wireless-Gaming-Maus, die ich wireless chargern kann,
wenn ich doch einfach ein Kabel dran machen kann und dann keine Batterien brauche, keine Akkus brauche und kein Wireless-Charging-System brauche?
Es spricht ja nichts dagegen, dass man das macht.
Aber man sollte zumindest noch Alternative mit Kabel haben, da braucht man das alles nicht.
Mich persönlich hat das Kabel an der Maus noch nie großartig gestört.
Aber man kann Kabel anstecken, das ist schon mal gut.
Ich muss mir mal durchlesen, was die gemacht haben.
Das ist okay.
Dann ist es okay, wenn man Kabel anstecken kann.
Aber wie gesagt, mich hat das Maus-Kabel noch nie gestört.
Es gibt Sachen, die nerven mich sofort.
Beispielsweise, wenn irgendwelche Mobile-Apps übelste Zeitverschwendungen drin haben anstatt ordentliche Funktionen.
Oder dass zum Beispiel die YouTube-App auf Android TV keinen richtigen Spulen-Knopf hat oder keinen richtigen Skip-Knopf oder kein Video-Neustarten-Knopf hat.
Da muss ich das mal vorstellen.
Ich habe schon dreimal im Stream gesagt, das ist mittlerweile immer noch nicht besser.
Die offizielle Android TV YouTube-App hat keinen Knopf, um das Video neu zu starten.
Das geht nicht.
Kann das Video nicht neu starten.
Wenn ich jetzt ein Video anmache, was irgendwie 2 Stunden geht und sagt dann zwischendrin, okay jetzt ist noch einer dabei gekommen, wir gucken es jetzt mal von vorne an, geht das nicht.
Dann muss ich 2 Stunden im 10-Sekunden-Rhythmus zurückskippen auf diese Fernbedienung.
Danach ist die Batterie leerbar.
Guck mal, der Eaxe ist da.
Und schon Namen reserviert.
Woe Classic.
Wobei, klar, hast du schon.
Habe ich ja schon gefragt.
Moin, muss die Freak.
Unge D.
Der Unge hat einen Vorteil hier auf Twitch.
Der hat schon mal Emotes.
Ich habe mittlerweile 11 oder 12 Emote Slots.
Und keine Emotes.
Kennst du eine Möglichkeit einen VNC-Sauber ohne einen angeschlossenen Monitor zu produzieren? Klar.
Du brauchst für einen VNC-Sauber keinen Monitor.
Brauchst du nicht?
Du musst einfach X installieren und einen VNC-Sauber.
Welche Klasse?
Wenn ich Woe Classic spielen sollte, also erstens nicht auf dem Stream.
Würde ich wahrscheinlich Shami spielen, ja.
Better Twitch TV plus FFZ beste.
Man braucht Better Twitch TV gar nicht mehr, wenn man FFZ hat.
Weil FFZ hat jetzt endlich die einzige Funktion von Better Twitch TV integriert, die ich vermisst habe.
Nämlich, dass man eine History hat von seinen Posts.
Max, warum sprichst du Woe wie Woe aus?
Damit es Leute wie dich triggert.
Das ist wie früher die Leute gesagt haben.
Max, sprich doch Kot bitte nicht Kot aus.
COD, man. COD.
Ich sag schon immer Woe.
Der Kollege auf der Arbeit sagt immer Woe.
Das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht, wie man zu Woe kommt.
Friisilul.
Friisilul checkt keiner bei mir auf dem Channel, warum Friisilul als Emo drin ist.
Oh Reddy, der war schlechter.
Also ich muss euch sagen, ich bin mit meiner G403 echt zufrieden.
Die ist nicht so fett wie die G502.
An was machen sich eigentlich genau die Bezeichnungen bei Logitech fest?
Haben die da auch irgendein gewisses System?
Das ist die G502 und das andere ist die G403.
Und eine G, G, G irgendwas ist dann auf einmal eine Tastatur.
Hat da Logitech irgendwie einen tieferen Sinn?
Can't you explain?
Tatsächlich?
Ach du Scheiße.
Was ist das?
Moment.
Das ist mir zu hoch hier.
Ich muss mal kurz die Modes ein bisschen zur Seite schieben.
Zugucker, Twitch Prime, Pog, Alter.
Was ist denn das für eine Tabelle?
Das ist eine Tabelle, wie Logitech ihre Mäuse benennt.
G502, G403.
Aber einen tieferen Sinn dahinter kann ich nicht erkennen ehrlich gesagt.
Also eigentlich, eigentlich, eigentlich hat es keinen Sinn.
Weil Wireless Mäuse gibt es überall, in allen Varianten Serien.
RGB gibt es auch auf allen Bahnen so.
Ja Posi, ich glaube die verstehen das selbst nicht.
Erinnert sich noch einer an die erste Razormaus?
Was ist das für ein Razor?
Diamondback?
Nee.
Razor, oh fuck wie hieß die?
Wie hieß die erste Maus, die mit Ball noch?
Copperhead kann sein Eax, Copperhead ja.
Nee.
Die sah aus, ey.
Ja, die war noch mit Ball.
Boomslang, genau.
Guckt euch das Teil mal an ey.
Das war auch genauso groß und klobig für eine Tabelle.
Das war auch genauso groß und klobig wie es ausgeschaut hat.
Und die hatte noch, die hatte noch, weiß nicht ob es irgendjemand, sie hatten noch einen Mausball drin ey.
Sieht eher aus wie eine Fernbedienung, wie eine unhaltliche Fernbedienung als eine Maus.
Für die damalige Zeit war es aber nice ja.
Liegt wahrscheinlich gut in der Hand, liegt gar nicht in der Hand.
Guck mal wie fett das Ding gewesen ist.
Sticke Maus.
Review Razor Boomslang von 2010, da hat es kein Mensch mehr verwendet.
Ja, so sah die erste Razor Maus aus und damals war es was anderes.
Damals war man richtig, richtig geil, wenn man so eine Razor Maus hatte.
Da war man richtig geil, alle sagten, oh krass ey, Gaming Maus, man ey.
Das war die erste richtige Gaming Maus, ansonsten gab es da nur so Geschiss, immer sowas gab.
Die Dinger waren damals voll beliebt, diese Intellimouse, ähm, ergonomic Dinger.
Und dann kam Razor mit der ersten Gaming Maus.
Und man war damals richtig cool, wenn man so eine Gaming Maus hatte, haben alle gesagt, boah ist das toll.
Darf ich mal anfassen, haben alle gesagt.
Und danach habe ich den großen Fehler gemacht, mir eine Intellimouse Explorer Wireless zu kaufen.
Und seit ich mir das Ding gekauft habe, die, die da, die da, die da, seitdem mag ich keine Wireless Mäuse.
Das Ding war im Nachhinein betrachtet der größte Crap ever ey.
Ich hab da mit CS gespielt damals.
Warum? Das Ding hatte, das Ding hatte sogar für die damalige Zeit keinen sonderlich guten Sensor.
Das Ding hatte fette Batterien drin, es war dementsprechend schwer wie Sau.
Die Batterien haben gewackelt, ähm, die Maus manchmal ausgegangen zwischendurch.
Ich musste es laufen, Batterien wechseln.
Ähm, es gab es sonst noch so, die war schwer.
War sonderlich, äh, ergonomisch war die auch nicht, obwohl sie so ausgesehen hat.
Man war es damit auch nicht schnell, das war komplett ungeeignet zum Spielen.
Ich war damals halt so bescheuert, dachte, ui, Wireless Maus, nice, das musste kaufen.
Ja, heute ist es was anderes, heute kannst du ohne Probleme Wireless Mäuse machen.
Hab ich auch vorhin gesagt, es spricht überhaupt nichts dagegen gegen eine Wireless Maus.
Außer vielleicht, äh, der Preis, wenn man sich so ein Charging Kit dabei holen will.
Früher hatte man wenigstens noch immer Batterien im Haus.
Äh, ich hab mittlerweile auch wieder für den meisten Kram Batterien im Haus.
Ich kauf mir einfach immer, äh, die China Batterien, also ne, wachsinn, stimmt nicht, ich kauf mir keine China Batterien.
Ich kauf mir, ich kauf mir das schon in, äh, Batterien ist ne Sache, die kauf ich mir in Deutschland.
Weil Batterien willst du nicht bei AliExpress kaufen.
Allerdings kauf ich mir da irgendwelche 20er Packs oder sowas.
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, sich diese kleinen Packs zu kaufen, wo dann irgendwie 15€ pro Pack.
Aber AliExpress Batterien ist wirklich ne dumme Idee.
Meinung zu Wireless Keyboards, ey, warum nicht?
Also wenn dich das Kabel stört, warum nicht?
Ich persönlich muss halt sagen, mich stören die Kabel nicht.
Und, ähm, ich sehs auch nicht ein, so ein Wireless Charging Kit zu kaufen oder sowas.
Aber das ist Geschmackssache.
Max, opa, naja, ich bin 35, ich bin ja auch schon, für diese Sache bin ich ja schon massive old.
Huge, huge age, äh, bin für, für den Kram hier.
Auch mit 35 bin ich sowohl hier auf Twitch als auch auf YouTube.
Ich mein, klar, mittlerweile haste viele ältere, noch ältere, ja.
Aber im Durchschnitt bin ich definitiv drüber.
Wo ich ja drauf warte, dass es ordentliche 4K 144Hz oder 4K 240Hz Monitore gibt.
Am besten noch mit V-Sync, G-Sync und dem ganzen Geschiss dabei.
Da warte ich ja noch drauf.
Ich weiß, dass das gar nicht so einfach ist.
Aber ich bin ja auch schon auf der Suche.
Ich bin ja auch schon auf der Suche.
Am besten noch mit V-Sync, G-Sync und dem ganzen Geschiss dabei.
Da warte ich ja noch drauf.
Ich weiß, dass das gar nicht so ohne weiteres geht.
Das ist mir auch schon, das ist mir schon klar, ja.
Allerdings würde es mir reichen, wenn der Monitor eben 144 oder 240Hz at 1080p kann,
allerdings einen 4K Panel hat.
Das wäre absolut big brain.
Da könnte ich nämlich meinen Desktop einfach auf 4K stellen und spiele dann auf 1080p mit 240fps.
Nee, gibt es auch nicht.
Ich weiß, wenn du meinst, der Boss ist back, du meinst diesen ultra teuren Asus.
Oder das neue Acer-Ding gibt es jetzt auch, ja.
Aber der hat auch nicht alles, was ich will.
Aber so einen 4K 240Hz Monitor hätte ich gerne.
Nicht, dass der 240Hz mit 4K machen soll.
Sondern er soll da 1080p mit 240Hz machen und 4K kann er mit 60 für den Desktop machen.
Das ist egal, so viel wie halt der gibt.
Und der Asus-Monitor, der 4K 144 oder was? 220?
Ich weiß es gar nicht, ob der da ist, das.
Der hat halt das Problem, dass der erstens ein bisschen teuer ist.
Also minimal teuer.
Stimmt, er hat einen IPS Panel, ja.
Und was da halt nervig dran ist, er hat einen Lüfter.
Das ist der einzige, also der erste und einzige Monitor, den ich kenne, der einen Lüfter braucht.
Ja, da oben ist der Lüfter drin.
Ich meine, einen Monitorlüfter, das stelle ich mir wirklich nervig vor.
Also das ist alles noch nicht so weit.
Ansonsten ist der Monitor echt sau geil, ja.
Soll aber nicht hörbar sein.
Also ich habe ein Video geguckt, da hast du das eindeutig Summen gehört, ja.
Ist die Frage, inwieweit es wirklich schlimm ist, ja.
Aber ich meine, ansonsten ist das wirklich ein geiler Monitor.
Gut, ich meine, mit 2000€.
Was willst du, was willst du?
Muss ja auch schon.
Seit wann bist du Twitch Partner?
Also ungefähr einen Monat jetzt, würde ich sagen.
Ja, es gibt Fernseher oder TVs, die angeblich 800Hz und sowas haben, aber das ist alles Marketing Bullshit.
Die haben ganz normale Zwischenbildberechnungen und die nennen sie einfach 800Hz, was mit 800Hz absolut nichts zu tun hat.
Und ja, ich weiß, du hast recht, es gibt Fernsehmonitore mit 120Hz.
Ich muss sagen, ich weiß nicht, ob es das Material überhaupt hergibt, ja.
Filmmaterial.
Ich weiß aber auch nicht, ob die 4K mit 120Hz machen.
Aber es geht auf jeden Fall.
Ich meine, sieht man ja an dem Monitor, da macht das ja auch.
Das dürfte auch so das Maximale sein, wahrscheinlich was über so die Displayport Spezifikation, die er unterstützt, drüber geht.
Da war es wahrscheinlich Schluss.
Ich habe mir mal von Asus jemand gefragt, das ist aber schon ein paar Jahre her, wann er denn denkt, wann es den ersten 4K 144Hz Monitor gibt.
Allerdings war das einer von der Asus Marketing Abteilung, da konnte er überhaupt nichts zu sagen.
Welche Monitor ich aktuell habe, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die heißen, das ist ein BenQ 144Hz Monitor.
Ich weiß nicht, wie die heißen, da steht leider kein Name drauf.
Schwarz ist nett.
Das war Asus, sag ich immer. Asus selbst möchte ja Asus genannt werden.
Ja genau, ich hätte halt gerne einen 4K Monitor, der 240Hz kann, allerdings muss er das halt auch nicht in 4K können.
Dass es da unterschiedliche Monitore gibt, die das jeweils das eine oder das andere können, ist mir schon klar.
Aber ich hätte gerne einen Monitor, der 4K kann, für einen Desktop und einen, der 240Hz auf 1080p packt.
Das ist einer.
Falls du einen Link findest, schick mir das mal, ansonsten kann ich mir Alexi Bexy nicht freiwillig geben.
Gibt paar Channels, die kann ich mir einfach nicht antun.
Ja das stimmt, 144Hz ist das beste.
Eine Sache ist, sollte jedem klar sein, der noch keinen 144Hz Monitor hat.
Ihr müsst gar nicht erst anfangen, euch irgendwie eine tolle mechanische Tastatur für Spiele zu holen.
Oder eine super tolle Maus fürs Spielen zu holen, wenn ihr keinen 144Hz Monitor habt.
Ein 144Hz Monitor, einfach alle Games auf Low stellen, dass du ordentlich FPS kriegst.
Ein 144Hz Monitor ist das, was alleine für sich genommen es schon ausmacht, ob du was killst oder komplett abkackst.
Oder ob du schlecht bist.
Also ein 144Hz Monitor, es sind Welten, es ist überhaupt kein Vergleich im Endeffekt mehr.
Du siehst Feinde besser, das ist ja logisch, du hast ja auch mehr Zeit.
Also wenn du dich drehst, hast du halt mehr Bilder in der Drehung drin.
Bessere KD, eindeutig auf jeden Fall.
Es gibt mal eine ordentliche, wenn man das mal untersuchen würde und würde Leute beobachten.
Oder die KD locken von Leuten, die ein 60Hz Monitor spielen.
Und dann umsteigen auf ein 144Hz Monitor.
Man könnte anhand ihrer KD erkennen, wann sie umgestiegen sind auf ein 144Hz Monitor.
Ach stimmt, HP hat auch was Neues.
65 Zoll, ja das ist aber dann eher für Leute, die im Wohnzimmer was spielen wollen.
Ist 14ms nicht ganz schön lang?
14ms ist doch ganz schön viel, oder?
Das ist ja der Input-Lag des Todes.
Ja, das ist ein Riesenunterschied, 60 oder 144.
Aber es ist ja auch Omen bei HP.
Das sagen sie immer, wenn sie irgendwelche Turniere oder sonst was sponsoren,
da haben sie immer ihren Sprecher dabei, der muss dann am Ende die ganze Zeit sagen
Omen bei HP.
Auf der Arbeit gibt es so einen Typ, der hat überhaupt nichts mit Spielen am Hut.
Null.
Der hat wahrscheinlich nicht mal einen Steam-Account.
Der hat aber eine Rocket Gaming RGB-Tastatur, wo ich mich immer frage, was genau macht der damit?
Das passt überhaupt nicht.
Das ist so der super, geleckt, aufgeräumte Schreibtischanzug, Dude.
Und der Schreibtisch sieht auch immer aus, als macht er da drauf gar nichts.
Aber was liegt auf dem Schreibtisch?
Ne, aber natürlich akkurat, rechtwinklig alles angeordnet.
Eine Rocket Gaming Tastatur.
Mit RGB.
Allerdings, das Witzige ist daran, mit Default-RGB-Beleuchtung.
Der hat die quasi eingestöpselt und nie was daran eingestellt.
Das ist dieser Default-Ripple-Effekt.
Vielleicht von seinem, so vielleicht.
Aber ich glaube, der ist noch zu jung.
Der hat keine Kinder.
Wie ist der drauf? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Was ist das denn?
Keine Ahnung.
Aber auf einmal hat er eine Gaming-Tastatur am Start gehabt.
Ich hab ja auf der Arbeit schon seit ganz einer Weile als Tastatur eine Ducky One Skyline.
Und was jetzt witzig ist, ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich mitgekriegt, diese Logitech-Sicherheitslücke, die es gab.
Also sprich, dass man wireless Sachen mitlesen kann.
Und jetzt ist ihnen aufgefallen, so nach dem Motto, fuck.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Jetzt müssen wir neue Tastaturen kaufen.
Und da hab ich jetzt mal vorgeschlagen, wie wäre es denn, wenn wir einfach allen Leuten, die lange am PC arbeiten,
wenn wir denen einfach eine mechanische Ducky One Skyline-Tastatur kaufen.
Ich hab die jetzt lange getestet, schon erprobt.
Und irgendwie haben die Leute überhaupt nicht gecheckt, was der Unterschied ist zwischen einer ordentlichen mechanischen Tastatur
und 15 Euro billig Rubber Dome von PC-Spezialist oder von Phobis, weil es das Phobis überhaupt noch gibt.
Gibt es Phobis noch?
Phobis.
Scheint es immer zu geben.
Phobis ist halt 2004 weg.
Und all die.
Hab ich auch gesagt, den Unterschied merkst du an ganz vielen Dingen.
Das ist so ganz schwierig, immer aus dem Kopf raus zu sagen.
Man merkt schon, der Tastenanschlag ist ganz anders.
Es fühlt sich irgendwie stabiler an, es fühlt sich irgendwie angenehmer an.
Ich hab dann versucht, so ein paar Vorteile aufzuzählen von mechanischen Tastaturen.
Das hat keiner kapiert.
Das hat keiner gecheckt.
Und dann hab ich gesagt, wir können es ja so machen.
Wir gehen einfach mal jetzt bei mir hin und wir nehmen so eine Standard billig 15 Euro Rubber Dome
und vergleichen die mal mit meiner Ducky One Skyline.
Ich hab es auch nicht für möglich gehalten, dass das geht.
Die haben keinen Unterschied gemerkt.
Also die meisten wollten das natürlich nicht ausprobieren, die haben sich natürlich darüber lustig gemacht.
Da dachte ich, was soll das schon für ein Unterschied sein.
Gut, das sind halt irgendwelche BWL Business Menschen gewesen, die im Leben wahrscheinlich noch nicht
irgendwas längeres getippt haben oder so.
Also was Technisches getippt haben, was gespielt haben oder so.
Und der das ausprobiert hat, der hat ernsthaft gesagt, der hat keinen Unterschied gemerkt.
Und wisst ihr, was der...
Das war aber 100 Pro, das war das Fake News.
Also 100 Pro hat er den Unterschied gemerkt.
Er hat allerdings das nur nicht gesagt, weil die Logitech Tastatur, mit der er das ausprobiert hat,
war noch so eine flache.
War noch so eine flache.
Bisschen wie die hier.
So, und ganz ehrlich, der wollte mir erzählen, er merkt keinen Unterschied zwischen sowas...
Nehmen wir mal, sowas hier stellvertretend.
Ne, das sieht anders aus.
Ist ja auch egal, ihr wisst was ich meine.
Zwischen sowas und sowas.
Und sowas.
Da muss ich doch nur drauf gucken und erkenne, dass die Verarbeitungsqualität hier einfach schon mal,
gar nicht vom Schreibgefühl und von den Tasten an sich, um Sonnensysteme entfernen besser ist.
Risch Pepega alles.
Ja, das stimmt, es kann...
Die Musik, äh, nicht die Musik, die...
Der Sound oder die Geräuschkulisse von mechanischen Tastatur kann schon nervig sein.
Allerdings, was man machen kann ist,
man kann sich einfach solche Ringe kaufen, sowas da.
So kleine Gummiringe.
Und die einfach unter die Tasten machen, auf die man immer besonders fest draufhaut.
Weil keiner haut alle Tasten gleich fest.
Also die normalen Tasten, so hier, was weiß ich halt, so eins bis neun, hier Q bis P und so.
Die normalen Tasten, ja.
Da haut keiner sonderlich fest drauf.
Wo ich halt persönlich immer übelst fest drauf haue, ist Numblock.
Numblock, Enter.
Weil ich mach, ich muss das auch mal kurz demonstrieren.
Ähm, ja okay, alles gut.
Ich muss das mal kurz demonstrieren, wie ich das hier mal mache.
Ähm, so, also ich tipp, ich tipp dann was ein.
Ja, Gott, piss dich, Alter.
Ähm, keine Ahnung, ich schreibe hier irgendwas.
Ich mach jetzt mal hier irgendwie sinngemäß irgendwie, blablabla.
So ein grandioses, grandioses Kommando, ja.
Oder irgendwie Echo Bloop 4 E in irgendwas mach ich, ne.
Und wenn das fertig ist, dann guck ich mir den Befehl, da geh ich immer so ein Stückchen zurück vom Monitor.
Und guck so drauf, also wenn das auf irgendeinem wichtigen System ist.
Oder irgendwo was, was, was, was, was kaputt machen könnte.
Guck ich immer noch mal kurz drauf.
Und wenn ich mir dann sicher bin, dass ich's ausführen, dass ich's ausführen will.
Dann haue ich immer mit der rechten Hand auf die Numblock, Enter-Taste.
So, so hört sich das ungefähr an.
So, und nachdem das so laut ist, habe ich unter die Numblock-Enter-Taste halt so ein paar, ja.
So ein paar Ringe, so ein paar Ringe drunter gemacht.
So, was ich dann, diese, äh, rechte Shift, rechte Shift haue ich auch immer übelst drauf.
Linke Shift nicht, wahrscheinlich weil ich das linke Shift mit dem kleinen Finger mach.
Und das rechte Shift mit dem Mittelfinger von der rechten Hand.
Ich hab eh so eine absolut nonkonforme Tastatur halt, also Tastatur-Finger, äh, Finger zu Tastatur-Mapping.
Caps Lock, ja, da mach ich auch mit dem kleinen Finger.
Also mein Finger-Mapping zur Tastatur ist absolut nicht Standard, ja.
Die Leute fragen sich ja schon, wie kann man so tippen.
Aber es funktioniert.
Ähm, ja, also rechte Shift und, und Control.
Control ist auch noch.
Also im Prinzip ist es eigentlich nur Numblock-Enter, Control-Shift und Backspace.
Backspace haue ich auch immer drauf.
Normaler Enter-Taste.
Also die, sagen wir so, die fünf Tasten habe ich, habe ich die Ringe drunter gemacht.
Und seitdem hat sich noch keiner irgendwie beschwert, dass ihnen die Tastatur zu laut wäre auf der Arbeit.
Ja, aber sei es drum, im Endeffekt, ich kann verstehen, wenn man sagt, ich hätte es ja nachvollziehen können,
wenn man sagt, ja, okay, wir wollen keine mechanischen Tastaturen, weil uns die Geräuschkulisse zu laut ist.
Das hätte ich ja verstanden.
Allerdings, dass jemand ernsthaft behaupten will, ja, dass er keinen Unterschied erkennt,
zwischen einer flachen Logitech 15 Euro Rubberdom-Tastatur und einer ordentlichen mechanischen Tastatur,
das ist einfach Fake News hoch, hoch, hoch 10, ja.
Kann nicht sein.
Vielleicht wollen die nur Kosten sparen, wenn die nur Kosten sparen wollten,
dann hätten sie einfach gesagt, Leute, verwendet eure Notebook-Tastaturen.
Das habe ich aber nicht gemacht.
Das Auto ist ein Arsch.
Notebook-Tastaturen kannst du verwenden, wenn das Notebook mobil ist.
Allerdings nicht, wenn es stationär in der Docking-Station drin ist, da kriegst du Anfälle bei.
Weil die meisten Notebook-Tastaturen eh übelste Crap sind.
Anti-Stress-Enter-Taste.
Ach, das ist so ein Kissen, was man daneben legen kann und dann haut man drauf.
So nach dem Motto Enter.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das gefällt mir, die Idee finde ich gut.
Kann man sich damit auch die Haare schneiden oder was?
Ach nee, die legt da ihren Kopf drauf ab, okay.
Taugt das auch als USB-Push-to-Talk-Knopf für den Fuß?
Ja, das ist eine richtig geile Idee.
Das ist eine übelst geile Idee.
So einen Pedal-Push-to-Talk-Button da draus zu machen.
Max, was kann diese Ducky?
Sag es bitte, verzw-
Was sie kann?
Die kann einfach nur gut gebaut sein, ja.
Die kann im Vergleich, was kann eine Tastatur?
Du kannst gut drauf schreiben, das ist alles was eine Tastatur,
äh, eine Tastatur auf den Schaltpunkt sieht.
Das ist alles, was eine Tastatur,
äh, auf den Schaltpunkt sieht.
Die kann die Tastatur nicht nur auf den Schaltpunkt sehen,
die kann die Tastatur nicht nur auf den Schaltpunkt sehen.
das ist alles was eine Tastatur können muss. Die gibt es in der Variante mit und ohne NumBlock,
ich hab die hier. Achja was die auch kann, was richtig gut ist, sind die Beschichtung
von den Tasten. Auf normalen Tastaturen hast du ja oftmals das Problem, dass sich die Beschriftung
und generell die Oberseite der Tasten Probleme macht mit einer Zeit, hast du hier null. Also
die Oberfläche der Tasten, die fühlt sich richtig angenehm an. Nicht wie meine überteuerte Corsair
RGB Tastatur, die ich hier vor mir hab. Crap Ding, hab ich das letzte mal schon erzählt. Überteuerter
Kack, der nicht richtig funktioniert. Gegen die Tasten hier bei dieser Corsair Tastatur sind die
Ducky Tasten meilenweit besser. Viel viel besser. Also die ganze Ducky Tastatur fühlt sich viel
hochwertiger an. Allerdings muss man sagen, die wiegt was. Also sag mal mal so für irgendwelche
Wechselarbeitsplätze oder Leute, die den ganzen Tag damit durchs Haus laufen, ist dann vielleicht
so eine mechanische Dingstastatur nix. Aber die können immer noch ihre Notebook Tastatur nehmen.
Ja also das Ding ist auch super als Selbstverteidigungswaffe einsetzbar. Also das Ding ist so,
also das Ding ist schwer. Wenn du das beschleunigst und einen vor den Latz haust,
der steht so schnell nicht mehr auf. Damit könntest du theoretisch sogar die unterschiedlichsten
Attacks durchführen. Die Dinge ist massiv. Du könntest damit quasi, könntest damit so
achstmäßig von oben den Tastaturspalt ausführen. Du könntest einem einfach nur von der Unterseite
vor das Gesicht knallen oder du könntest auch einfach Anlauf nehmen und die Tastatur irgendwie
entgegengrammen. Also die hält das aus. Also der Typ oder deine Hände, je nachdem, sind eher
kaputt, bevor diese Tastatur kaputt geht. Also das ist wirklich stabil das Teil.
Der Knärbär, die Tastatur sieht aber ein bisschen mitgenommen aus. Aber gut, ein bisschen Farbe ab,
macht ja nix. MacBook, also die Tastatur vom neuen MacBook gefällt mir gar nicht. Diese hyperflache,
wie heißt das Ding nochmal? Butterfly? Butterfly Keyboard. Das finde ich hat ein ganz mises
Schreibgefühl. Ich meine, das werden natürlich Apple Fanboys nicht zugeben. Die sagen beste
Tastatur aller Zeiten. Aber ich persönlich fand das Schreibgefühl nicht gut da drauf.
Und sie sind wohl sehr anfällig gegen Staub und Dreck. Also schon mal nix für Leute, die damit
wirklich arbeiten wollen. Weil wenn du wirklich an einem Notebook arbeitest, dann bewegst du das
auch mal von einem Arbeitsplatz zum anderen oder im Zweifelsfall sitzt du auch mal irgendwo draußen
was arbeiten oder futterst mal während du was machst. Diese Tastaturen sind wohl extrem anfällig
für Staub, Schmutz und Probleme. So anfällig sogar, dass Apple auf Nachfrage, habe ich auf
Reddit gelesen, die die Tastaturschutzfolie mit dabei gibt. Wenn man sich beschwert.
Max, wenn du dich entscheiden müsstest, was das ist, was das für eine Frage. Egal, gehen wir mal
von dem theoretischen Fall aus. Max, wenn du dich entscheiden müsstest zwischen einer Laptop
Tastatur und einer scuffed Maus. Was ist denn eine scuffed Maus? Eine eklige Maus oder was?
Okay, also Maus die sackt quasi. Was ist eine Tastaturschutzfolie? Da muss man mal MacBook
eboard cover. Das da, das da. Das ist eine Tastatur für eine Tastatur, also eine Tastaturauflage für
eine Tastatur, die man nicht erkennt so richtig, dass es eine Tastaturauflage ist und weil die
Tastatur zu anfällig ist. Das ist halt, das ist halt typisch typische Apple Kratzer. Ja genau,
also zwischen was würdest du dich entscheiden? Ehm, einem Laptop zwischen Laptop Tastatur und
einer scuffed Maus oder einem PC ohne SSD. Wie ein PC ohne SSD und dafür eine ordentliche Maus
und Tastatur dran. Da würde ich einen ordentlichen PC mit ordentlicher Maus und Tastatur nehmen,
bevor ich Laptop Tastatur und eine scuffed Maus nehmen müsste. Da würde ich nämlich einen PC
nehmen und einfach die Hälfte vom RAM als RAM-Disk nehmen und dann scheiß auf SSD.
Ja das ist halt, das ist halt typische Apple-Bogic hier. Weiß man nicht.
Ja die Thinkpad, die alten Thinkpad-Keyboards waren, waren nice. Generell waren die alten
Thinkpads nice. Die waren nämlich auch sehr massiv, da konntest du auch kein Display abbrechen
oder so. Aber die waren zu, eigentlich waren die alten Thinkpads schon zu schwer für mobil arbeiten.
So, ich wollte ja eigentlich mal gucken, was es für Gamescom Pressekonferenzen hier gibt.
Also sowas gibt es denn. Die Xbox-Konferenz. Montag! Oh das ist nice Leute, dass das Montag
ist, da bin ich daheim. Ach ab 18 Uhr, da wäre ich auch so daheim. Ja da müssen wir
Montag uns wohl Gamescom angucken würde ich sagen. Nächste Woche Montag ist das schon.
Mal gucken, ob sie wieder ihren komischen Stream auf Mixer machen und zu früh einschalten
wie letztes Jahr, wenn ich mich noch dran erinnern kann. Mixer, Omega-Lull, Mixer. Xbox-Gamescom
ist ja nur Xbox. Gut. Pupke. Dass Pupke aus dem Early Access kommen könnte, das ist vollkommen
unbedeutend, ob das im Early Access ist oder nicht. Das Game ist raus, das Game ist spielbar,
das Game hat eine riesen Anhänger erschafft. Scheiß egal, ob das aus dem Early Access
kommen oder nicht, außer dass man das Marketing technisch besser verkaufen kann. Ob sie wieder
super excited sind, ist seit diesem Jahr auf Konferenzen nicht mehr so angesagt. Ich meine
klar, diese Standardredewendung, dass sie super thrilled, excited und proud to announce
und sonst was sind, das werden sie immer noch erzählen, aber der neueste Trend was
die Marketing-Konferenz angeht ist, dass man versucht die Leute mitzureißen. Das hat man
auf der E3 gesehen und das hat man auch auf der Apple-Konferenz gesehen. Anstatt einfach
nur Bullshit-Kram zu labern, machen die Leute auf der Bühne öfters mal yeah oder sowas
in der Richtung. Wer die Apple-Konferenz gesehen hat, weiß, was ich meine. Die stehen auf
der Bühne und versuchen so mitreißend zu sein. Nach dem Motto, ich bin super excited, was
Neues anzukündigen, yeah, so in der Hoffnung, die Leute flippen jetzt mit aus. Das ist Gamescom-Publikum,
das wird nicht ausflippen. Die sind skeptisch. Gamescom-Publikum ist skeptisch. Allerdings
trotzdem, Mehrzahl der Leute klatscht trotzdem mit, weil sie sich sonst fremd schämen müssten
für den Typ da vorne steht, dass keiner klatscht. So, was gibt's hier, Gears 5, guck mal an.
Okay, direkt danach im Anschluss, 18 Uhr Xbox, 19 Uhr, Gott, das geht doch so gut. Ich bin
übrigens ein großer Fan von, dass die Gamescom früher ist in der Woche. Ach ja, stimmt,
Axel Forst ist ja auch auf der Gamescom dieses Jahr. Den hab ich ja schon wieder ganz vergessen.
Direkt danach um 19 Uhr kommt Google Stadia Connect. Das wird so sucken, Leute, ich sag's euch.
Es wird so sucken, diese ganze Stadia-Geschichte. Ich glaub das aus zwei Gründen. Erstens,
es ist Google, was für mich ein großer Faktor ist, dass es sucken wird. Ich will nicht sagen,
dass Google keine gescheiten Produkte rausbringen kann, allerdings hat Google die letzten Jahre
irgendwie kein, finde ich zumindest, kein glückliches Händchen, was so groß angelegte
neue Sachen angehen. Und der zweite Grund, warum ich glaube, dass es sucken wird, ist,
mit Geld und Infrastruktur kann man auch gegen Lichtgeschwindigkeit nichts machen.
Das ist das größte Problem, was diese ganzen Remote-Gaming-Dienste haben. Die mögen ganz
sinnvoll sein für jemand, der wirklich nichts daheim hat und beispielsweise das neue Assassin's
Creed spielen will, mit einem Controller, Singleplayer, kein Ding, kannst du ohne Probleme
wahrscheinlich über so einen Streaming-Dienst machen. Aber ich glaube, die Leute, die das
wirklich tun wollen, sind relativ gering, weil die meisten dieser Leute, die das eventuell
treffen könnte, die wissen davon gar nichts, die wollen gar kein Assassin's Creed spielen,
die wollen Candy Crush, Omega-Lull-Saga spielen oder sowas, die wissen das überhaupt nicht,
und die, die das spielen wollen, haben eigentlich in der Regel auch eine Plattform, auf der
sie spielen können. Und mal davon abgesehen, für alle anderen Sorten von Games, außer
eben sowas wie ein Third-Person-Parcour-Ding wie Assassin's Creed oder Gears of War Singleplayer,
also alles, was Singleplayer ist und nicht gar so schnell und nicht gar so präzise ist,
also quasi alles, was man Singleplayer mit dem Controller spielt, dafür ist das okay,
aber ich weiß dann immer noch nicht, wo der Vorteil ist zu ich kaufe mir eine Xbox oder
ich kaufe mir eine Playstation, geh dort in den Store und lad mir den Kram runter. Viel
besser aussehen wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Ich weiß nicht, also ich gehe persönlich
davon aus, dass wird der Roar-Krepierer des nächsten Jahres, dieses und nächsten Jahres
werden Stadia. Aber vielleicht liege ich diesmal auch komplett falsch. In der Vergangenheit
habe ich mit so Sachen öfters ja mal richtig gelegen. Ich sage nur mal, dass PUBG es sackt
und Fortnite übrigens abgehen wird. Das war für mich meilenweit zu sehen schon, das war
wahrscheinlich für jeden zu sehen, der ein bisschen in den letzten Jahren Sachen gespielt
hat, weil PUBG damals einfach unfertiger halbgearrer Crap war und Fortnite Leute dahinter gesessen
haben, die wissen, wie man Games macht. Beide Spiele nicht die Spiele, aber das war zu sehen
ja und ich finde in dem Fall ist es auch oder das Anthem, dass Anthem sacken wird, das war
auch meilenweit zu sehen finde ich, wenn man sich einfach nur die Sachen in Ruhe angeguckt
hat und nicht zu sehr gefanboyt hat und ich finde es ist auch bei Google Stadia wieder
zu sehen, dass das der Roar-Krepierer wird, aber vielleicht liege ich auch komplett falsch.
Wie geht es deinem Rücken jetzt wieder besser? Ich weiß nicht, was ich gemacht habe. So,
die wollen aber montags, montags ist der erste Tag, wobei montags ist überhaupt nicht der
erste Tag. Geht es nicht erst dienstags los? Dienstags ist jetzt ja irgendwie Pressetag
und Mittwoch ist normal oder wie war das? Ach dann ist Montag so dieser Vorbereitungstag,
ok. Danach kommt schon gleich die Gamescom Opening Night Live Conference. Ach wieder
der Typ, den kann ich nicht aussprechen. Ich sprich bei denen aus. Ich weiß wer es ist,
ich habe aber keine Ahnung, wie man ihn ausspricht. Chef? Chef? Laili? Keine Ahnung, wie man ihn
ausspricht. Was sagst du eigentlich zu den neuen Konsorten? Ich bin immer wirklich sehr
gespannt. Offizielle Specs gibt es noch nicht, oder? Es gibt nur diese geleakten Specs. Geoff.
Was? Geoff? Ernsthaft? Ich glaube es gibt noch keine offiziellen Specs, ne? Die geleakten
Specs haben wir uns ja mal angeguckt und die sahen finde ich endlich mal wieder nach einem
ordentlichen Sprung aus. Ach gerne, ja gut, das hat man vermutet. Das hat man ja auch
schon vorher vermutet. Aber die Specs, die wir uns mal angeguckt haben, die geleakt wurden
vor einer Weile, die sahen auch recht realistisch aus. Gucken wir mal. PS5, Playstation 5. Das
klingt irgendwie nicht so vertrauenserweckend. Guck mal, Rützen. Ich weiß nur, dass die
PS5 auch PS4 Spiele abspielen kann. Die wären unglaublich blöde, wenn das nicht geht. Die
wären so unglaublich bescheuert, dass ich es eigentlich nur Nintendo zutrauen würde,
dass die nächste Konsole nicht die alte Konsole abspielen kann. Also früher hätte ich verstanden,
dass die PS4 keine PS3 Spiele abspielen konnte. Das habe ich verstanden. Das war eine komplett
andere Architektur. Aber es wäre unglaublich dämlich, vor allem für Microsoft im Hinblick
auf ihr Rückwärtskompatibilitätsprogramm, es wäre unglaublich dämlich, würden Microsoft
und Sony ihre neuen Konsolen, die ja im Endeffekt stinknormale PC-Hardware sind, zumindest die
Architektur, ganz normales X86-Gedöns, wie die alte Generation, das nicht rückwärtskompatibel
zu machen. Das wäre einfach komplett in den Hirn verbrannt. Denn wie gesagt, dem einzigen,
dem ich das zutrauen würde, sowas nicht zu tun wäre Nintendo. Also Nintendo traue ich
zu, dass wenn die eine Switch, eine Switch 2 rausbringen, eine richtige neue Switch,
dann alte Switch-Games nicht drauf. Nintendo traue ich das zu. Die anderen zwei, glaube
ich, sind dazu zu schlau für, was das angeht. Soll die PS5 nicht 8K-Gaming unterstützen?
Das glaube ich nicht. 8K-Gaming ist kompletter Bullshit. Es ist ja nicht mal 4K-Gaming Standard.
Nicht mal ansatzweise Standard 4K-Gaming. Wo stehen denn jetzt die Specks?
Console will offer 8K. Also das Einzige, was damit gemeint sein kann, ist, dass das Ding
einen Display-Port hat oder einen Monitor-Port, der 8K ausgeben kann. Das ist aber auch das
Einzige. Das ist genauso, wie sie damals gesagt haben, bei der 360 und der PS4, dass das Full-HD
Gaming-Konsolen sind. Es gab, bis auf ein paar einfache 2D-Spielchen und so grafisch
überhaupt nicht so anspruchsvolle Sachen, kein Spiel, was auf dieser Generation 1080p
gelaufen ist. Man muss ja auch mal sagen, die erste Auflage von Xbox One und PS4, selbst
da war das nicht Standard, dass Spiele in richtig echtem 1080p mit konstanter Bildrate
gelaufen sind. Also 8K, 8K. Die sagen, im Prinzip ist es ja nicht gelogen. Die Konsole bietet
8K-Gameplay. 8K-Gameplay kann alles sein. 8K-Gameplay kann Slyther oder Agar.io im Browser
im Hauptmenü sein. Das ist auch 8K-Gameplay. Die lügen ja nicht. Das ist ja nicht mal
Fake-News. Es stimmt. Wenn man es genau nimmt, stimmt das wahrscheinlich. Die haben einfach
einen Monitor-Ausgang, der halt eben ein 8K-Display anstreuen kann. Fertig. Kein Game
wird halbwegs anspruchsvoll auf dieser Konsole mit 8K laufen. Der Patrick fragt, wen kann
ich bannen? Ich würde sagen, dieser Game 402. Den müssen wir mal bannen. Vor allem, warum
402 und nicht 420? There will be a disc drive included. Ja, Gott sei Dank. Finde ich gut.
Finde ich gut. Aber Sony ist halt so ein bisschen natürlich noch ein Video-Media-Sonstwas-Laden.
Die spekulieren natürlich immer noch darauf, dass sich auch Leute eine PS5 kaufen, weil
sie immer mal Blu-Rays und sowas abspielen wollen. Ich finde es aber gut. Ganz ehrlich,
Konsolen sollten immer die Möglichkeit bieten, ohne Internetanschluss mit einem gekauften
Spiel einzulegen und zu spielen. Was ist das da oben eigentlich schon wieder für ein komischer
Kringel? Das ist doch ein Fake-Render, oder? Das Ding sieht doch gar nicht so aus. Das
Ding sieht gar nicht so aus, wie sich irgendein Sony-Fan gedacht hat, dass das Ding aussehen
könnte. Äh, Enderboy, du kannst darauf wetten, dass da eine AMD-CPU drin sein wird. In der
PS5. Ich sehe jetzt da zu CPUs nichts. Achso, what we know so far. Äh, okay, das ist das
einzige, was Sony gesagt hat, dass es eben eine neue Ryzen sein wird. Aber das war auch
sowas von klar, ehrlich gesagt. Auch im Hinblick dessen, dass die aktuellen ja schon AMD-CPUs
drin haben und eine bessere CPU für so eine aktuelle Konsole wie den Ryzen wirst du eigentlich
nicht kriegen. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Sache. Ähm, ich gehe auch mal davon
aus, dass sie diesmal ordentlich viel RAM haben wird. Ob die wirklich diese, was hatten
sie geleakt, mal 24G RAM haben werden, weiß ich nicht. Also, wozu? Aber ich denke mal,
wie viel haben die aktuellen 8? Also ich denke mal, na gut, das mindestens, aber es kann
auch 12 oder 16 werden es schon sein. Aber ich frage jetzt, so viel RAM brauchst du
in der Konsole nicht unbedingt, ja. Also ich meine, du hast kaum ein Game, was ansatzweise
irgendwie 16, 16G RAM brauchen würde. Vielleicht machen sie es rein, weil es gerade billig
ist. Wobei es wäre auch nicht billig, wird ja vermutet, dass es DDR6 RAM wird oder sowas
oder DDR5. Man weiß es nicht. Wir müssen mal warten, was da wirklich für Specs, was
da reinkommt, ja. Ja, ja, es ist genau das, genau das, was ich sag. 8K ist einfach nur
dummes Gelaber. Das Ding hat halt einen Monitoranschluss, wo du einen Monitor anschließen kannst, der
8K hat. Und das war's. Sonst ist da dran nichts 8K an dem Teil. Tja. Wo, ja Gamescom wollten
wir ja gucken. Also Microsoft, nee, Gamescom Opening Night. Mit dem Dude, den ich nicht
aussprechen kann, okay. Dann gibt es hier was weiß ich, die üblichen verdächtigen
Bungee. Gucken wir mal was Bungee da braucht. Ja Bungee, Bungee bringt doch jetzt Destiny
5 auf Steam, ne. Unterstützt HDMI denn überhaupt 8K? Ich weiß nicht, was die aktuellste HDMI
Spezifikation unterstützt. Du hast recht, es wird kein Displayport sein, es wird wahrscheinlich
schon HDMI sein. Was kann denn, was kann denn das neueste? Ja, hier. Yes. Ja, 2.1 kann
das. 2.1 kann das und 2.1 kann das auch schon mit, ohne HDR. Ja. Aber nur 30 Hertz. Ahja.
Ja gut. Ja, das ist ja nochmal das, na gut, das auf der Konsole, auf der Konsole ist 30
Hertz ja okay. Auf der Konsole, wissen wir ja, sorgt 30 Hertz für das, wie haben sie
gesagt, das Filmerlebnis, ja. Also das cineastische Filmerlebnis. 30 FPS. Was ist denn DSC? Cinematic,
genau. Was ist denn DSC? Warum brauchen die alle? Display Stream Compression, aha. Mit
Display Screen Compression können sie auch mehr. Ja, ganz ehrlich, Blockwatcher denke
ich mir auch. Ich persönlich werde mir als erste Konsolengeneration die neue PS5 und
Xbox, wie auch immer sie dann heißen mag, es wäre mal wieder Zeit für XP. Microsoft
macht das ja gerne. Das wird bestimmt irgendwie recycelt, das nächste ist eine Xbox XP oder
sowas. Xbox.net wäre auch nochmal sowas, das Microsoft wieder aufwärmen könnte. Aber
ganz ehrlich, Blockwatcher sehe ich auch so. Scheiß auf PS5 und neue Xbox, Hauptsache
Compact Company 3 kommt. Xbox Vista, ja. Ja, das denke ich auch. Ich werde mir auch wie
gesagt die neuen Konsolen nicht holen bei Release. Ich habe den Fehler gemacht, ich habe den
Fehler bei der aktuellen Konsolengeneration noch gemacht. Release Xbox 360, Release PS4,
Release Switch und wie oft benutze ich es? Gar nicht im Endeffekt. Wenn ich was spiele
dann PC, PCMR. Den brauchen wir eigentlich. Oh Leute, den brauchen wir noch. Den haben
wir noch gar nicht drinne hier. Den haben wir noch gar nicht drinne. Florius, PC, ja.
Den brauchen wir noch. Den brauchen wir noch. So. Ja, wunderbar.
Den brauchen wir, wenn es mal wieder um die neue Konsolengeneration geht. Muss ich echt
sagen, also dieses Board damals zu programmieren, auch wenn es absolut nicht fertig ist, war
wirklich eine gute Idee. Ich wüsste gar nicht, was ich hier manchmal ohne die passenden
Füllchen machen würde. Aber GTA kommt wahrscheinlich nur auf Konsolen erstmals her. Das haben
sie das letzte Mal ja auch so gemacht. Und ganz ehrlich, dann eben nicht. Ja, da warte
ich halt bis es auf den PC kommt. Auf den PC wird es auf jeden Fall auch kommen. Und
es ist, es hat sich die letzten Jahre ganz klar und auch das war abzusehen. Ja, das war
schon so 2013, 14 abzusehen, dass die Zeit der reinen Konsolen-Exklusivsachen vorbei
ist. Es gibt immer noch welche, vor allem auf der PS4 und auf der Switch, oder hauptsächlich
auf der PS4. Aber es gibt mittlerweile, die meisten größeren Games kommen mittlerweile,
sie sind halt was von Sony finanziertes, kommen für PC und Konsole. Ja, und eine Menge an
Games kannst du auch nur auf dem PC ordentlich spielen und gibt es glaube ich gar nicht
für Konsole. Müssen wir mal in Steam gucken. Also mittlerweile muss ich echt sagen, ich
bin der Meinung, das war die richtige Sache, dass ich gesagt habe zum Konsolengenerationswechsel,
ich meine ich habe schon immer auf dem PC gespielt, ich habe 20 Jahre, aber ich hatte
ja mal zu der Zeit von 360 und PS3 hauptsächlich Konsole gespielt, aber zum Konsolengenerationswechsel
hatte ich ja damals gesagt, ich habe es mir zwar gekauft, aber ich habe mir damals schon
gedacht, so gesagt, ne, wird mal wieder Zeit ordentlich auf dem PC zu spielen. Da habe
ich auch den Vorteil, Felix, Felix hat geschrieben hier Red Dead Redemption 2, dass ich den Xbox
gekauft. Da habe ich den Vorteil, dass ich irgendwie gefühlt einer der 0,01% der Weltbevölkerung
bin, den GTA nicht interessiert. Ich sage nicht, dass die Sachen von Rockstar schlechte
Games sind oder so, aber Open World Games an sich, so wie sie GTA sind, das ist einfach,
das habe ich auch schon oft gesagt, das ist einfach nicht meins und selbst Witcher 3 wäre
nicht meins gewesen, wenn sie nicht so eine gute Main Story gehabt hätten, die im Endeffekt
dafür gesorgt hat, dass die Open World einfach Kulisse für die Main Story war und man jetzt
nicht quasi Open World criaten musste. So hat mir Witcher 3 ganz gut gefallen und ich
muss halt sagen, auch das GTA Gangster Szenario ist auch nicht unbedingt jetzt so meins, ja,
ich kann aber wie gesagt, ich sage nicht, dass das Game schlecht ist, ich kann schlicht
und greif nichts sagen zu dem Game. Das letzte GTA, was ich gespielt habe, war GTA 3? Oder
was ist Vice City gewesen? War das 3? Nö. Welches GTA ist Vice City? 4, ok. Gut, 4,
aber ne, GTA 4 ist es nicht. GTA 4 hieß doch sogar GTA 4, oder? Ach so gut, die Benahmung
bei denen ist auch Fail, verstehe, verstehe. Also Vice City war das letzte, was ich gespielt
habe, ihr habt ja gesehen, es war 2002. Vice City war das mit dieser merkwürdigen Laufanimation.
Ich bringe es jetzt auch durcheinander. Was ist das mit dieser merkwürdigen Laufanimation?
Ja, genau. Ja, genau. Ja, was gibt es sonst noch auf der Gamescom? Deine Meinung zu Outer
Wilds? Jetzt muss ich erstmal in mich gehen, was überhaupt Outer Wilds genau gewesen ist.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Sagt mir gar nichts. Outer Wilds. Open World, schau mal da. Sogst
du Autorenzspiele wie Forza Horizon? Eigentlich auch nicht unbedingt jetzt, ne. Was das? Sagt
mir gar nichts. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das für ein Game ist. Kann ich null zu sagen,
sagt mir überhaupt nichts. Scheint aber noch relativ neu zu sein. Was mich wirklich überrascht
hat ist, jetzt nicht, ich spiele es nicht, aber was mich wirklich überrascht hat ist
der Support, der das Game nach Release bekommen hat. Das muss ja mittlerweile ein wirklich
gutes Game sein. Also No Man's Sky muss mittlerweile ein richtig gutes Game sein. Es gab als letztes
ein riesen Update. Es gibt mittlerweile einen ordentlichen VR-Modus, wo Spiele wie No Man's
Sky natürlich richtig von profitieren. Das ist ein richtig gutes Game mittlerweile. Ja,
das ist hier der Marketing-Schwätzer von No Man's Sky. Steam. Ja, natürlich hat es insgesamt
auch schlechte Bewertung. Recent Reviews sind auch schlecht. Also mittlerweile ist es wirklich
nicht übel, was man halt so liest. Ich spiele es ja nicht selbst, aber der Support für
ein Game nach Launch muss richtig gut sein. Spiel holen tue ich es mir nicht. Es juckt
mich nicht, wo wir wieder beim Thema sind Open World, die mich eigentlich nicht großartig
interessiert. Ich habe gelesen, es gibt jetzt kein neues Duke Nukem, sondern auch kein
Remake, ein Spiel mit wohl starken Duke Nukem Anleihen, was auch auf der Duke Nukem 3D Engine
basiert. I Am Fury, das glaube ich. Das wollte ich schon mal auf Steam holen. Das ist aber
halt eher was für Leute, die alles Zeug spielen. Es kam heute oder gestern raus. Es hat übelst
gute Bewertung auch überall. Viele Leute sagen WoW Classic wird der Untergang für das
normale WoW, wie es jetzt schon 15 Jahre gibt. Was glaubt ihr? Es war alles schon mehr oder
weniger der Untergang von WoW. Es war alles schon mal der WoW Killer. Blizzard rechnet
ja selber nicht damit. Hat man zumindest den Eindruck selber nicht damit, dass Classic
der wahnsinns langfristige Erfolg wird. Da sieht man schon daran, dass es erstens relativ
wenige Server gibt und dass sie diese komische Phasing Server Clustering Mechanik jetzt wieder
mit eingebaut haben. Obwohl es Classic ist und viele ja quasi sagen, zumindest mein letzter
Stand, Eax, ich glaube du warst da jetzt in letzter Zeit öfters mal geguckt, was halt
überhaupt nicht Classic-like ist und was halt aber viel bringt, wenn die Spieleranzahl eben
sich so verhält, wie Blizzard das vielleicht erwartet. So nach dem Motto Riesenhype Boom
am Anfang und dann innerhalb von 1, 2, 3 Monaten, da gehe ich mal von aus. Stimmt,
dann kommt das neue Doom eigentlich, das dauert auch nicht mehr so lange. Ha, so ist ja bald.
Immer lang. 3 Monate noch. Das ist nice. Control, da bin ich mal scharf drauf. Also Control,
da warte ich wirklich drauf, da bin ich echt, echt gespannt drauf. Ich hab mir letztens
mal nochmal in Ruhe den Trailer angeguckt und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass die Hauptdarstellerin
von Control die gleiche ist wie aus Quantum Break. Also die hat auch eine recht, ohne
jetzt spoilern zu wollen, die hatte auch eine recht große Rolle in Quantum Break. Allerdings
ist das halt ein Game, das ist so ein typisches Remedy Game, das wird wahrscheinlich ne richtig
gute Story haben. So ein Singleplayer von 7, 8 Stunden und danach ist vorbei, aber man
fand das Game übelst geil. So waren bisher alle Remedy Games. Also am meisten freue
ich mich tatsächlich auf Control. Ich bin ein quasi riesen Remedy Fan, was das angeht.
Die haben nur gute, Sam Lake hat nur gute Games geschrieben bisher, die sie gemacht
haben. Das erste Max Payne war übertrieben nice, auch wenns grafisch heute kacke aussieht.
Am ersten Max Payne hat er ja selbst noch Max Payne gespielt. Max Payne 2 war auch
übelst nice. Max Payne 3 hatten sie ja nix mal mit großartig zu tun, das war ja Rockstar.
Alan Wake war auch ultra nice das Game. Alan Wake hatten sie das Problem, dass das Game,
oder ich finde was ein bisschen problematisch war, dass das Game eigentlich nur ordentlich
abgeschlossen ist, weil man alle DLCs gekauft hat, wo man richtig merkt, die haben einfach
die letzten 3, 4 Levels oder Missionen, oder Levels ja, aus dem Hauptgame entfernt und
als DLCs veröffentlicht. Das war nie, das normale Ende von dem Game war nie als Ende
von Alan Wake gedacht irgendwie, sondern nur das DLC Ende. Er gibt auch viel mehr Sinn
als das, wo er dann unterirdisch da in diesem Häuschen sitzt. Alan Wake war übertrieben
nice. Quantum Break hab ich mittlerweile auch mal ein bisschen gespielt, ist auch übelst
gut. Ich bin noch nicht ganz fertig. Und das wars glaub ich. So viel haben die nicht gemacht,
aber es war jedes Game was rausgekommen ist. Es war Singleplayer, es war ein klassisches
Story Driven Singleplayer Game, was Remedy immer rausgehauen hat. Und die große Stärke
von Remedy ist halt, dass Sam Lake wirklich, er ist es wahrscheinlich nicht allein, er
wird nicht jede einzelne Dialogzeile in einem Game selbst schreiben, oder jede einzelne
NPC in einem Game selbst schreiben, aber er ist halt der Hauptwriter bei Remedy. Und
die große Stärke von Remedy ist halt, dass die eben Sam Lake haben, der gute Storys
schreiben kann. Gute Storys, die man schön in Games umsetzen kann. Hello Invasion 65.
Also wenns eine Sache mehr geben müsste, dann so Läden wie Remedy und Leute wie Sam Lake,
die ordentliche Spiele, Storys schreiben können. Und dann halt der passende Entwickler und
auch die Leute im Hintergrund, die das umsetzen können. Da könnt ihr echt noch ein bisschen
was von brauchen. Oder davon könnt ihr echt noch ein bisschen mehr geben. Ja was gibt
es denn sonst noch so auf der Gamescom hier? Was ist daran toll hier, wen haben wir da?
Okay, Activision, Bandai Namco, Bungie, Capcom, EA, Epic, der EA Epic Koch. Das ergibt sogar
in diesem Zusammenhang irgendwie Sinn, ne? Der ehemalige deutsche Community Manager von
Battlefield hieß doch Koch. Die Community Manager von Battlefields war ein E. Irgendwie
ein bisschen, weiß nicht. Ehe bin ich mir den nicht so richtig warm geworden. Was, Kerbal
Space Programm? Okay, wusste gar nicht, dass es das noch gibt. Sony ist auch am Start,
Square Enix ist am Start, Ubisoft. Death Stranding natürlich, was sonst, ja. Death Stranding
muss. Der wird wahrscheinlich wieder die Leute verwirren. Was hältst du von GOG Galaxy 2?
Ich finde die Idee nicht verkehrt. Ich glaube nach wie vor nicht, dass ich das großartig
durchgesetzt werden werde. Aber die Idee, dass man einen Client hat, wo auch eine Firma
dahinter steht, die andere Clients unterstützt, finde ich prinzipiell schon mal ganz gut.
Gears 5 juckt mich persönlich jetzt nicht so. Ich hab zwar die anderen Gears-Teile gespielt,
aber die wurden, finde ich, immer schlechter. Vor allem auch, weil sie in Gears zu viel
Wert auf, auf, äh, wir tun mal so, als wäre es eine emotionale Story gelegt haben. Gears,
einfach, einfach die Charaktere, wie die angelegt sind, mit denen kannst du keine emotionale
Story machen, da fuck. Das ist wie, wenn du jetzt, keine Ahnung, wenn du den Doom Marine
nehmen würdest und machst da jetzt irgendwie einen Drama draus oder so. Und genauso wenig
hat das mit den Gears of War Leuten funktioniert. Ich mein, ich sag's immer, ich sag's immer,
wie ich hab's schon oft gesagt im Team. Markus Phoenix aus Gears of War, das ist der farbloseste
und, und abziehbildmäßigste Actionheld aller Zeiten, äh. Also, so profilloser geht nicht
als Markus Phoenix. Und mit so Leuten, mit so Charakteren haben die versucht, quasi in
Gears Abteil 3 dann die übelst emotionale Story zu machen. Das hat halt nicht funktioniert.
Deswegen bin ich auch bei Gears 5, da ist es nicht so scharf drauf. Serie, Sam-Drama-Serie,
genau so was. Das geht einfach nicht. Du kannst nicht einfach anfangen und siehst so quasi
hirnloser Muskelmann mit Kettensägengewehr. Allein schon, allein schon diese Beschreibung
klingt total beknackt, aber ich mein, im Endeffekt ist das ja Markus Phoenix, ja. Muskelverpackter
Mann mit Kettensägengewehr. Hinstellen und krasse Sprüche machen im ersten Teil und
danach ab Teil 2 sagen, oh heute jetzt, aber jetzt, jetzt sind wir emotional. Das hat null
gepasst. Deswegen ist Gears of War 1 auch immer noch der beste Gears of War-Teil. Also
rein vom Gesamtpaket her, spielerisch mag Gears 2 besser sein. An sich, ähm, wie war
es das jetzt schon? Und das war's. Moment, was? Es gibt dieses Jahr nur zwei Pressekonferenzen,
wir machen hier diese Google, äh, die, die Gamescom Opening Night raus. Es gibt sonst
nix mehr? Wo sind denn so die anderen üblichen Verdächtigen? Wo sind Blizzard zum Beispiel
oder was Ubisoft oder wo ist, äh, wo sind die alle? Haben die keinen Bock? Ich kann's
verstehen. Wer hat schon Bock auf die Gamescom, ja? Aber wundert mich jetzt. Ich mein, immerhin
Blizzard war übelst, übelst fett auf der Gamescom vor ein paar Jahren. Die haben ihr
neues WoW-Endon exklusiv auf der Gamescom damals vorgestellt. Weil's einfach vom, vom,
vom Rhythmus her besser zu WoW gepasst hat. Das war übrigens der, der Gipfel, der, der
Gipfel des, des Fanboy-Tombes, was ich gesehen hab, je, was ich jemals in meinem Leben gesehen
hab. Die Legion, die, die WoW Legion Pressekonferenz auf der, auf der Gamescom, ähm, wo sie Legion
angekündigt haben. Das war wirklich der Gipfel des Fanboy-Tombes, das hab ich so noch nicht
gesehen. Also die, die, die WoW-Fans, ey. Das war wirklich der Hammer, ey. Die haben
alles gefanboyt. Die hätten, die hätten, die hätten dort revelen können, keine Ahnung.
Illidan hat jetzt einen sechsten Fußzeh und die WoW-Fans in dem Publikum wären, wären,
wären, wäre einer abgegangen bei. Also das war wirklich der absolute Gipfel des Fanboy-Tombes,
was ich da erlebt hab bei Blizzard. Also die Leute, die dort gesessen haben, die hätten
wahrscheinlich auch Diablo Mobile gefeiert. Also ein paar, ne, der überwiegende Teil
waren stinknormale Gamescom-Leute, die da gesessen haben. Aber da, sie hatten halt, wahrscheinlich
waren das irgendwelche Leute, die im Forum, im Forum den, den Gamescom-Besuch gewonnen
haben oder so. Das machen ja manche Hersteller. Aber das waren die richtigen Hardcore-Fans,
ey. Ja, das finde ich auch, das finde ich auch immer ein bisschen affig, wenn sie dann
den Typen haben, die im Hintergrund dann machen. Wo du immer denkst, okay, was war da dran jetzt
toll? Und im Hintergrund, beste, nice, krass, krass, super excited, super excited, genial,
genial. Das verstehe ich auch nicht. Aber ich mein, das sind halt, du brauchst halt
die Vorklatscher irgendwie, ne. Da gibt's ja, es gibt, es gibt, das heißt ja nicht,
da gibt's ja, da gibt's ja, da gibt's ja wirklich irgendein Wort für, für diese Leute. Und
die sind ja absichtlich auch an den Stellen platziert, wo sie platziert sind. Du hast
heute noch kein Sellout gemacht. Ich hab heute noch nix gemacht. Mit eineinhalb Stunden on,
ich hab noch nix gemacht. Wollt ihr übrigens mal den Fortschritt sehen vom, vom Versand-Tracksor?
Okay, also Gamescom-Konferenzen sind dieses Jahr mau. Aber das Schöne ist, dass sie
alle montags sind, und zwar montags, 18, 19, 20 Uhr. Das ist top, weil da können wir montag,
also hier, nächste Woche Montag, also in drei Tagen, machen wir dann ab 17.30 machen wir
Gamescom, äh, anguck, Reaction-Stream. Also im Prinzip läuft das ja so raus, wir gucken
uns den Stream an, und ich erzähl zwischendrin, wie dumm ich alles finde. So wie das, so läuft
das ja eigentlich immer, ja. Obwohl man ja sagen muss, manchmal, manchmal kommt's ja
auch vor, dass ich manche Sachen auch gut finde. Aber ehrlich gesagt, wer vielleicht
den letzten Gamescom-Stream gesehen hat, ich glaub, ich glaub hauptsächlich mach ich mich
drüber lustig, über Marketing-Geschwätze, oder? Ich glaub, ja, also, das dürfte überwiegend
ein Teil sein. Aber manchmal sind Spiele dabei, ich weiß noch, wo wir uns, wo wir uns Ori
angeguckt, war das Ori? Irgendwas haben wir uns angeguckt, da war ich voll begeistert,
von was ich das erste Mal gesehen hab. Also es kommt durchaus noch vor, dass ich manche
Sachen gut finde. Du hast noch kein Sellout gemacht, achso, ja hab ich ja grad schon gesagt,
ich hab aber nix gemacht. Ja, zum neuen Cyberpunk, da bin ich auch mal gespannt drauf, weil denen
trau ich zu, dass sie ein Open-World-Game machen, was mich auch interessieren könnte.
Ich hab übrigens überlegt, nachdem ich jetzt ja bei AliExpress die 50 USB-Kabel bestellt
hab, hab ich mir überlegt, kann man nicht bei AliExpress auch 50 USB-Sticks bestellen?
Weil ich mein, wenn ich jetzt 50 USB-Kabel hab, warum nicht auch 50 USB-Sticks? Aber
das ist doch schon. Was, 256 MB? Omega-Lol, 256 MB, 50, warum? Weil, weil's geht. Was,
ist das ein Vibrator? Warum findet man das, wenn man, wenn man nach 50 USB-Sticks sucht?
Genau, Mokathos. Das ist natürlich kein Vibrator, das ist eindeutig ein Massagegerät. Gar
nicht, wie man auf die Idee kommen kann. Na, muss ich da mal gucken. Also, 50 USB-Sticks,
warum nicht? Ich hab mir vorhin überlegt, wenn, wenn Kabel, wenn 50 Kabel, dann warum
nicht 50 USB-Sticks? Und die Kabels, wir haben das letzte Mal drüber gesprochen, ich hab
jetzt mal ein paar ausprobiert, bis jetzt hatte ich noch kein Kabel dabei, was kaputt
war, tatsächlich. Ich hab aber auch nicht beide Anschlüsse ausprobiert, ich hab nur
die Mikro-USB-Variante ausprobiert, nicht die USB-C-Variante. Ach ja, ich seh's grad
zu, guck mal. Zimmer viel zu teuer. So, ähm, was gibt's denn sonst noch zu gucken, ja?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich hatte heute überhaupt nichts vor, ach so, ja, ich wollt euch ja den Versand-Tracksor
zeigen, den, den, den neuesten Varianten, Versand-Tracksor. Also, ich würd sagen, da
ist jetzt, äh, also was, was das Tracking angeht und was das, das, das, das, ähm, Browser
Frontend angeht, kann man das, denke ich, so lassen, wie's jetzt ist. Jetzt muss ich,
jetzt muss ich nur diese Benachrichtigungs-, äh, Benachrichtigungsfunktion und E-Mail-Scan-Geschichten
programmieren. Oh, also ich zeig's euch mal. Die neueste Versand-Tracksor-Version. Huge
Tracking. Track, Protect, wie war das, Protect, Attack, Attack, Protect, Track, oder was auch
immer. So, das sind ein paar Test-Sachen, die ich hier drinnen hab. Wir tun mal so, als
wären wir auf einem iPhone oder so, oder komm, wir machen's mal, Fullscreen ist auch egal.
Ähm, wir haben eine LKW-Emoji, das ist schon mal die allerwichtigste Neuerung, die man
dran sieht. Und was richtig cool ist, das Tracking ist mittlerweile Multithreaded, ihr habt's
vielleicht gesehen, falls ihr's nicht gesehen habt, zeig ich's euch noch mal. Äh, ups.
So, das war das falsche, was ich gerade gestartet hab. Äh, ah, was auch immer. Äh, ich, ich,
der Versand-Tracksor wird nochmal gestartet. Falls ihr's nicht gesehen habt, es lädt Multithreaded.
Pass mal auf. Ja, DPD ist manchmal langsam, da kann ich nix für. Jetzt, jetzt ist er grad
übelst, übelst lahm und macht nix. Aber wenn DPD nicht so langsam ist, dann lädt er Multithreaded.
Wahrscheinlich hängen einfach gerade alle vier Threads, die abfragen. Weil DPD immer
wieder übelst lahm ist. Ich kann euch zeigen, dass es prinzipiell funktioniert. Ah, nee,
das funktioniert auch nicht. Der muss initial einmal durchgelaufen sein, dass es funktioniert.
Also jetzt hängt's. Wahrscheinlich geht's in der Minute. DPD hat manchmal so Phasen,
da sind sie einfach nicht erreichbar und hängen. Nutzt du eigentlich einen Mail-Client? Wenn
ja, hast du was unter Windows und Linux. Ich bin Thunderbird nicht mehr ganz. Ich hab auch
Thunderbird mittlerweile. Überall. Immer noch, also hab ich schon die ganze Zeit. Für
das bisschen Mail komm ich mit Thunderbird gut aus. Und Thunderbird ist der einzige Open
Source, also Multi-Plattform Open Source Mail-Client, der auch Kalender und Termine
und so Zeug unterstützt. Was ist der Vorteil von Thunderbird? Naja, es läuft auf jeder
Plattform und es gibt's für jede Plattform. Und es kann eigentlich alles, fast alles, was
man braucht von E-Mails. Also was ist denn mit DPD jetzt los? Ups, das ist das falsche.
Oh, guckt, die DPD-API ist gerade kaputt. No Status Found for Shipment. Die DPD-API ist
gerade kaputt. Das ist natürlich ziemlicher Sack, dass die DPD-API kaputt ist. Huge.
Aber ich kann euch zeigen, dass es prinzipiell funktioniert. Wir machen mal, wir machen mal
eine DHL, DHL-Tracking rein. Oh, keine Ahnung, Tracking-Number. Komm, und lassen wir mal
gleich zugestellt. Inklusive Sendungsverlauf. Oh, das ist ein Bug. Das ist ein Bug im DHL-Tracker.
Der darf hier kein Flugzeug anzeigen, der müsste das Auto anzeigen. Ach, ich weiß auch, woran
das liegt, weil ich im DHL-Tracker noch auf Englisch stehen habe und nicht auf Deutsch.
Ich hab's hier noch auf Englisch drinne stehen. Ich muss es auf Deutsch stellen, ich hab nämlich
DHL-Abfragen auf Deutsch umgestellt. Ah, DPD-Spaktrum, DPD ist grad nicht da. Aber
es funktioniert, nice. Und die Karte ist mittlerweile richtig gut, Leute. Passt mal auf. Ist das
nicht nice? Wie das Auto fährt? Habt ihr das gesehen? Dark Theme, nice. Ich beende das mal
und starte das mal neu. Ich weiß nicht, an DPD liegt oder an mir liegt, aber wenn da
genau Status kommt, das ist die Meldung, die DPD versteckt. Die generiere ich ja nicht.
Starten wir nochmal neu. Ach, jetzt funktioniert's. Okay. Ah, zeig ich's hier nochmal. Genau,
jetzt hat man hier den Status drinne. Und der kann alle Zwischenschritte mittlerweile
darstellen. Da hat hier Transit, Transit. Übrigens, was witzig ist, dass gerade DPD
die Statusmeldung nicht auf Deutsch hat. DPD hat die Statusmeldung auf Englisch, auf Estländisch,
auf Lettisch und auf Litauisch. Also, ist nicht auf Deutsch. Huge brain. So, und hier
sieht man's auch ganz gut. Kann man sich anzeigen lassen, hier, wie das Ding gefahren
ist. Wir brauchen mal einen mit mehr als zwei Zwischenschritten. Der hat mehrere Zwischenschritte.
Und da fährt der Emoji-LKW. Da sieht man, wo das Ganze ist. Das ist eigentlich schon
ganz nice. Ich hab jetzt viel im Background gemacht, was man auf den ersten Blick nicht
sieht. Er hat zum Beispiel, dass er sich automatisch aktualisiert. Also, wenn ich jetzt hier was
eintrage, was es nicht gibt, sieht man auch hier erst mal Loading Data. Und nachdem man
dann geguckt hat, ob es das Ganze ist, ich mach jetzt nix, aktualisiert sich das vorne
hier. Invalid Tracking ID. Ich hab jetzt eingebaut, dass man Sachen wieder löschen kann. Genau,
dass man was adden kann, ist auch neu. Das ging ja vorher nicht. Die eigentliche Sache
mit Benachrichtigungen, Home Assistant, MQTT-Integration und E-Mail scannen muss ich noch machen. Aber
die Basics, also das, was funktionieren soll, funktioniert. Also, es ist wirklich mittlerweile
echt ganz nice, das Ding. Ja, so Leute, das war jetzt heute etwas spontaner Stream, ohne
irgendwie großartiges Programm zu haben. Wir machen jetzt schon Schluss, weil ich muss
erstens mal übertrieben aufs Klo und dann muss ich mich mal ein bisschen um meine Katz
kümmern. Ihr guckt mich hier schon ganz vorwurfsvoll an, warum ich den ganzen Tag mir nichts gemacht
hab. Und ihr wollt ja nicht daran schuld sein, dass ich die ganze Zeit ungefähr so angeguckt
werde vom Schrank. So ähnlich. Das wollen wir nicht, ne? Deswegen muss ich jetzt Schluss
machen. Wir sehen uns morgen, ihr Leute. Macht's gut, bis denn. CU.